how do you not crack and break when
others are trying to get you to pin you
against the person you're working with
how do you manage that see
frankly number one bush had really thick
skin so it didn't bother him and when it
doesn't bother the boss it tends not to
bother the staff now if it bothers the
boss of your boss is thin skin throws
stuff how do they do that why they
report that to men you're under pressure
yeah he wasn't yeah so I didn't have to
be
secondly I believe when the the most
beautiful thing about the White House
and I don't care what party you are yeah
is when you believe
it is so easy to fight and stand your
ground and you take the incoming you try
to pay attention maybe you'll learn
something from the incoming you can
rebutt it stronger learn you got a
vulnerability maybe we should address
this
but you take the incoming and you turn
it around because you believe
and that's how democracy should work if
I can't stand there and explain what the
president is doing and why he's doing it
and if I can't do it articulately and we
take incoming then maybe we deserved it
but if I can explain it and say it
articulately and drive more support for
it that's the job
I love that how different was he I had
the uh opportunity to uh invite him to
an event which was I saw the picture
right I had the opportunity to write him
to the event and that was in 20
2019. same event we had Kobe Bryant
delayed Kobe Bryant at and I had
President Bush there and he I'm coming
out of the bathroom he's coming to the
bathroom it's the first time we make the
connections like hey hey Patrick I'm
gonna wait for you over there okay great
he goes to the bathroom comes back a
bunch of people there with the Secret
Service sticker and you know and then we
had a nice 45 minute conversation in the
back talking to him and then on stage
when I interviewed him telling the
stories opening up and when we announced
him being a keynote speaker it was not
like I'll remember we're at uh a hotel
in Dallas and I announced our two
keynote speakers and the first one I'm
just watching and I said guys I want to
find out the reaction so put the camera
on them there's about of 1500 people
there and we're announcing it that's
going to be at Mirage is going to be 6
000 people there so I said okay
first Speaker we're gonna have at the
event it runs the cameras ready they're
Live President George W bush
what the reactions were Priceless
dumbfounded and some were like oh my God
our president's coming but it was a very
different and then I said hey you know
Kobe Bryant they lost their mind right
and they were so excited anyways
President Bush comes up and I interview
him and he talks personal life what
things he did what things he changed
just being very open about the whole
thing and then we're doing pictures
succession with pictures
and I cannot tell you how many people
who were you know not supportive and
send me messages you shouldn't have
brought them you shouldn't have done
this they're like look I don't know if I
agree with policies but I like the guy I
kind of like him on how he is you know
wow I like this guy this would be a guy
I would want to have dinner with what I
I like and then so every time everybody
was taking a picture half of them were
happy to take the picture the other half
were like I got to tell you I thought
look one girl said I thought you were
the Antichrist but I like talking to you
this was amazing listening to you thank
you so much for coming out how was he
off camera behind closed doors was he
funny was he a Storyteller was he a
prankster was he always serious was
there a topic he always wanted to study
like is he a guy that studied Andrew
Jackson did he have a favorite President
that he would always read about is there
a certain book he would he play
backgammon is he a Domino's guy is he a
chess guy what was he like like you know
the clip on Last Dance you know you see
the security guy coming in come on one
more time yeah rolling a dice 20 bucks
boom he beats Michael and he goes like
this right and he does the Michael thing
back at him and Michael's pissed off
what was he like off stage off camera
I've heard what you said so many times
from people who have seen him in his
post-presidency
he is gregarious he's engaging he's
self-deprecating he's witty as can be
and funny and fun he was a great boss I
don't care what you industry you're in
or what ideology you have you want a
boss like George W bush he was inspiring
he was tough you were going to work your
tail off for him you never want to let
him down but boy was he a good guy who
was loyal and took care of you and you
in exchange gave him your loyalty
because that's the kind of relationship
of Boston and gender in any industry
um but yeah he was uh he was a towel
Snapper witty lots of jokes you know he
would keep things light now after
September 11th that went away for quite
a while but that's his nature and and it
came back
um he has a marvelous touch that
inspires people through seriousness and
humor and in his post-presidency and
I've done many of these events and
speeches with him where you know to
moderate a q a
um people get to see his humor and you
saw it there I'm sure you know and most
of it's self-deprecating most of it
makes fun of himself yeah it's very hard
for some people to do that so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks right if you believe future
looks bright get your latest Future
looks bright hat of valuetainment it
says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]